this video was made possible by
curiositystream sign up for any
subscription at
curiositystream.comwendover
and get free access to nebula where you
can watch my new trivia show
or our upcoming wendover original
back during world war ii a young doctor
named
r adams cowley spent his deployment on
the battlefields of europe
treating patients on the precipice
between life and death
he observed through this experience that
those suffering from the medical state
of shock
following a traumatic injury were placed
on an often certain
but not immediate path towards death
this exposure to those patients
developed his life's
goal he sought to take those on the
certain path towards death
and nurse them back to life he wanted to
be able to treat
then untreatable major traumatic
injuries
some years later in 1960 he neared
closer to this goal by opening
in some corner of the sprawling
university of maryland medical center
a two-bed unit dedicated to treating
major trauma patients
the first such department in the country
kelly started with about a 40
survival rate but as his experience
accumulated
and his techniques refined more and more
patients
survived it turned out that the certain
path towards death for major trauma
patients
was not so certain however
he also observed that even his reliable
techniques couldn't reverse the course
of death
if a patient took too long to get to him
he posted that once someone experienced
major trauma
they had a roughly 60-minute window to
reach him
or else it was too late the problem was
that
by the time other doctors transferred a
patient to cali
that window had often passed the system
just wasn't suited for this sort of
speed
therefore he reinvented the system
first he lobbied for ambulances to bring
trauma patients directly to him
or eventually other trauma units rather
than just to the nearest potentially
unequipped hospital
as was standard protocol at the time
second
he convinced the maryland state police
to use their helicopters to bring trauma
patients to his unit
dramatically reducing the average time
to care
cali dubbed this 60-minute window the
golden hour
and the principles behind it are now the
central guiding light
of the emergency medical service system
its purpose
is to stabilize triage and transport
as fast as possible because according to
this golden hour principle
faster is always better in trauma
medicine
the vast majority of the american
population can reach their nearest
hospital within the golden hour
with a traditional ground-based
ambulance system
but not all this is a map of the u.s
and these are the areas more than a
60-minute round-trip drive to the
nearest hospital
there are vast swathes of these sparsely
populated american west
where ground ambulances cannot fulfill
the golden hour principle
especially given the recent spate of
closures of unprofitable
rural hospitals in fact it's not even
very difficult to run into this problem
if you were to drive from denver to las
vegas to major american cities
most of your trip would take place on
interstate 70
which would lead you through the
desolate area of the san rafael swell
if your car were to crash here your
nearest hospital would be over
90 minutes away in moab and this is just
on the
interstate the central circulatory
system of the us
it's plenty possible to get much much
further from medical care
and so to plug these gaps to get
patients in the most rural areas
and dire circumstances to care as fast
as possible
that's where the country's air ambulance
system
steps in across the nation
there are some 900 air ambulances
stationed
at hundreds of bases each of which
expands the number of people
able to reach hospital within an hour
each of these aircraft have the
potential to change
lives each and every day and play a part
in many people's worst days when your
life is on the line
every minute counts so these aircraft
save life and limb with every flight
right well to a certain person
maybe an executive at an air ambulance
company for example
these 702 words up until now probably
all sound correct but are they really
everything up until now covered one
simple principle
more trauma patients brought to the
hospital within 60 minutes
equals more lives saved it can't
possibly be
that the central tenant of emergency
medicine
the golden hour principle is just wrong
right well in 2001
an academic review posed that exact
question and found
quote no large well-controlled studies
in the civilian population that either
strongly support
or refute the idea that faster is
universally better
in trauma care essentially it's said
that the golden hour principle
could be true but despite the fact that
the entire ems system
operates on the collective assumption
that it is true
we just don't know for sure
so in response researchers sought an
answer
plenty found that the answer was yes as
one would expect
faster transport to the hospital does
improve survival outcomes
but plenty others didn't this one found
that
quote the time factor involved in
managing and transporting hypotensive
penetrating injury victims directly to a
regional trauma center
does not appear to be related to an
adverse outcome this one concluded with
quote no pre-hospital time less than 90
minutes exerted a significant adverse
effect upon survival
while this one found quote no
significant difference
in survival after traumatic injury when
the eight-minute ambulance response time
criteria was exceeded
similar results failing to find a
statistically significant link between
total pre-hospital time and survival
outcomes
were found in this study and this one
and this one and this one and
countless more 20 years onwards from
that academic review
the only certainty here is uncertainty
there is no scientific consensus on
whether the golden hour
is truly relevant today uncertainty
is fine it's part of the scientific
process
the entire american air ambulance
industry
is built on a collective unverified
assumption
that the golden hour principle is indeed
true however since we're dealing with
assumptions
let's tackle another one when you think
of air ambulances
you probably imagine a flight from here
to here
seen to hospital of course that's what
you see in the movies
but these sorts of flights only account
for about a third of air ambulance trips
the vast majority of their business
involves hospital
to hospital transfers you see the trauma
care system that dr cowley innovated
evolved into a nationwide hierarchical
network
essentially there are five levels of
trauma centers hospitals certified to
treat patients with major traumatic
injuries
and as you go up in the levels the
centers become more advanced
and less widespread levels five and four
mainly deal with stabilization and
initial evaluation
prior to transport to a higher level
center while level
3 centers will have on-call surgeons who
could start to resolve
simpler trauma cases level 2 centers
have surgeons with 24-hour immediate
availability
rather than just on call in addition to
certain specialists
then those most advanced level 1 centers
have everything conceivably necessary
for any trauma case
including specialists across all fields
and the ability to treat a case all the
way from initial presentation
through rehabilitation which can be a
multi-year process
level one trauma centers are incredibly
expensive to run
and therefore need a critical mass of
patients to cover costs
consequently it's very possible to be
more than 600 miles or 950 kilometers
from one while in the lower 48
or 2000 miles or 3200 kilometers from
one
wall in alaska due to this potential
distance
a major trauma case outside a major city
would typically go
first to a level three four or five
trauma center
which are far more commonplace where
they be stabilized and evaluated to
determine whether they need to be
transferred to a more advanced facility
so someone in a vehicle crash in the san
rafael swell on i-70
in utah would likely first go to the
moab regional hospital which is a level
4 center
if the doctors and nurses there
determined the patient needed a higher
level of care they would be transferred
in this case to st
mary's hospital in grand junction
colorado which is a level 2 center
then if that hospital determined the
patient
had such complex and specialized
injuries that even they
couldn't handle it the patient would
likely be transferred to denver health's
level 1 trauma center since each of
these transfers would take
hours by ground the decision would
almost certainly be made
for major trauma cases to use an air
ambulance
this is the bread and butter of the air
ambulance business
and surely this saves lives
right well yes and
no in one study of major trauma patients
suffering from certain high mortality
injuries
patients admitted to level 2 centers had
a 29.7
mortality rates while those admitted to
a level 1 center
only die 25.4 percent of the time
more advanced trauma centers do save
more lives and therefore conventional
wisdom would assume
that transfers to higher level centers
save lives but conventional wisdom
almost always misses the nuance of a
situation
according to another study some quarter
of adults
and half of children transferred to
level one trauma centers
are brought there unnecessarily in other
words they've been subject to
secondary over triage where the more
advanced center ends up discharging them
after completing treatment that a less
advanced center would have been plenty
capable of
now a certain level of secondary
over-triage is to be expected and
even encouraged after all it's better to
be safe than sorry
but again we need that nuance for
an over-triaged patient they would have
survived if they had stayed in a level 3
center for example
and they did survive when they ended up
in a level 1 center
so the health outcome was the same but
for those patients transferred by
an air ambulance they received something
else
an absolutely massive
bill a conservative estimate
puts the average price of an air
ambulance flight in the u.s
at 27 900 others put that figure
even higher well into the 30 or 40
thousands
meaning it's very possible and even
common for someone to be charged
more for a quick hospital ride to or
from the hospital
than they make in a year another
counter-argument though
a human life to the holder of that life
is essentially
invaluable any cost to save it is worth
it
but the problem is not the cost it's the
price
the cost for air ambulance companies to
operate a given flight
according to the companies themselves is
somewhere between 6
and thirteen thousand dollars that
shouldn't
be possible as in quite literally the
rules of economics
say that that gap between cost and price
shouldn't be possible because in a
normal free market
for normal products competition would
drive down prices
far closer to costs since lower prices
increase
demand and companies can increase
profits with greater market share
but the american air ambulance market is
very far
from normal every product in the world
can be mapped onto a graph
that looks like this price on the y-axis
quantity purchased on the
x this is what a normal product looks
like
as price goes down quantity purchased
goes up
there are some exceptions to this for
example
certain luxury goods plot like this on
the graph where higher prices actually
stimulate higher demand
to an extent although almost no product
will look like this
this however is the relationship between
price
and demand for air ambulances as price
increases
it has zero impact on demand it's easy
to understand why
the people purchasing and paying for air
ambulance flights
have no agency over whether or not to do
so
the decision to use an air ambulance is
made by first responders or
doctors not the often unconscious
patient so there is a complete lack
of market forces working to lower the
price
when a free market isn't working to
regulate the allocation of
goods and services into the most
societally advantageous configuration
which in this case would be the greatest
possible availability of air ambulances
at the lowest possible prices
economists would describe that as a
market failure
in cases of market failure even the most
staunchly libertarian economist
would tend to agree that the only
solution at that point
would be external intervention typically
by the government
and so this massive critical industry
charging vulnerable people massive
crippling prices
can't possibly be completely unregulated
right wrong in fact
not only is the air ambulance industry
not regulated
but it seemingly can't be you see back
in 1978
congress passed the airline deregulation
act
ending the government's ability to
regulate the affairs of airlines
this led to a dramatic decrease in
airfares and a dramatic
increase in flights essentially it paved
the way for the us to become the world's
largest aviation market
but when it sought to deregulate
airlines that truly meant
all airlines through the years as
various states have attempted to fix the
market failure of the air ambulance
industry
providers have successfully argued in
court
time and time again that because they
are technically airlines
and because the airline deregulation act
prevents states from regulating airfares
states cannot regulate the prices air
ambulances charge
there is truly no limit to what they can
charge
but wait there is another unique market
force in the american healthcare
industry
that could solve this problem that's of
insurance
right you see most insurers in the u.s
have a network of providers that they
cover and
if a patient uses an out of network
provider they are charged a
far higher rate or are subject to an
annual spending cap
in non-emergency circumstances it's
often possible to find
an in-network provider and many states
and recently the federal government too
have passed legislation limiting
out-of-network bills for emergencies
but of course thanks to the airline
deregulation act
those don't apply to air ambulances
in the u.s some 77 of air ambulance
flights are built out of network
meaning patients are on the hook for all
or at least the vast majority
of those 30 or 40 or 50 thousand dollar
air ambulance bills this is
once again a symptom of market failure
for most medical services insured
patients have the ability to choose
which provider they go to
they have the ability to choose to go to
an in-network provider
which is a market force that pushes
providers to accept as
many types of insurance as possible if
they didn't they would lose business
and those insurers have the scale to
negotiate prices
down with air ambulances though since
patients have zero ability to choose
which provider they use
or even whether they use one at all
there are no market forces pushing
providers to bring more insurers in
network in fact they often get paid more
from out-of-network patients meaning
they not only lack incentive to bring
insurers in network
but market forces are pushing them to
minimize the number of carriers
in their network air ambulance providers
and more specifically the private equity
firms that now own the majority of them
have figured out just how exploitable
this market failure
is since 2000 the number of air
ambulances
in the u.s has more than doubled to
nearly 900
and the average annual flight hours per
helicopter have dropped from a high of
600 in 2003
to almost 450 as these companies further
saturate
the market in the same time period
average prices
have more than tripled it's tough to get
a good gauge of just how much these
companies are profiting on the plight of
americans in the most vulnerable moment
of their lives
largely because almost all the major
players in the industry
are now owned by private equity firms
and therefore don't report their
financial results
what's clear though is this in 2017
according to one study air ambulances
owned by private equity firms
charged about double with those owned by
hospitals
or non-profits did the cost to operate
non-profit and for-profit air ambulances
are not dramatically different
so the only reasonable conclusion is
that these
private for-profit air ambulances are
pocketing
thousands upon thousands of dollars in
profit
per patient there is nothing stopping
this industry from charging
higher and higher rates not market
forces
not regulation nothing and so these
private equity companies
having realized this will keep jacking
up prices
and turning highway accidents and heart
attacks into higher returns for their
investors
right now this is an industry that can't
be stopped there is however potentially
momentum for reform
with the recently passed no surprises
act which caps out of network charges in
emergencies
but it's unclear exactly how this can
and will
impact the air ambulance industry when
it takes effect in 2022
given the protections of the airline
deregulation act
any doctor knows the words primum
non-nuchaire a latin phrase that
translates to
first do no harm it's a maxim that
guides
every med school bioethics course and it
essentially recognizes that
in medicine it is possible to do more
harm than good
it's why when someone reaches the final
days or hours of their life
and the outcome is certain the decision
is typically made
to withhold treatment because it can
only harm
treatments come with physical emotional
and financial burdens
so they're simply not worth it when the
path towards death
is irreversible when air ambulances are
used
the goal is to reverse that path and in
many cases
they do however the best research
into the matter estimates that for every
100 air ambulance flights
four lives are saved that means
that in 96 cases out of 100 the patient
or their next of kin walks out of the
hospital having lost
a year of income they walk out having
pushed back retirement by year
having lost the ability to send their
kids to college or buy a house
or go on vacation they've lost a
non-trivial quantity of quality of life
in 96 cases out of a hundred doctors
using private air ambulance providers
are forced
to violate their hippocratic oath they
are forced to make
a split-second decision that does harm
and changes lives for the worse all
because
at the end of the line there's some
wealthy investor
in some private equity firm who prefers
a 10.5
return on investment over 10.4 percent
and nobody's doing anything to stop them
any longtime wendover viewer will have
heard of the curiosity stream nebula
bundle deal
you sign up for any curiosity stream
subscription at this link and you get a
free nebula account
too but for those of you who have not
yet signed up
now's a really good time that's because
i just released a three-part trivia show
featuring brian from real engineering
jordan herrod and dave from city
beautiful plus i'm releasing a brand new
wendover original that was shot a while
ago
on location next month of course the
only place to watch this is on nebula
as their business model makes bigger
projects like this financially possible
and there's quite literally never been a
better time to sign up
that's because our sponsor curiosity
stream is having its biggest ever sale
41 off meaning it works out to less than
one
dollar a month and by signing up at
curiositystream.comwendover
any subscription is bundled with a
nebulous subscription for the exact
same price plus curiosity stream has
tons of great new stuff too like dream
routes a three-part film that focuses in
on three of asia's most storied and
historic roads
which really helps scratch any travel
itch you might have
right now so if you want to watch all
wendover and
hi videos early and ad-free plus all our
exclusive originals
plus all of curiosity streams great
non-fiction shows and films
make sure to head over to
curiositystream.comwendover
and you'll be helping to support this
and tons of other independent
educational creators
while you're at it